let's broaden out a little bit and
discuss where we go from here
i'm joined by three women one of
westminster's most independent
minded mps diane abbott also
the co-founder of the women's equality
party catherine mayer
and as well the co-chair of the mayor of
london's violence
against women and girls panel joan smith
thank you all so much for joining us
this morning um
ask you all the same question first and
then we'll move on um cressida dick is
it time for her to go diane abbott
we would hope that if she goes
that she's actually replaced with
somebody better
someone that doesn't deny institutional
racism exists in the police force
and someone with a much less
heavy-handed
approach to public order issues
catherine
uh i think that her position is
untenable but the danger
of just seeing her resign is that this
will then become
a problem about her leadership as
opposed to being something systemic
as opposed to being something that is
not just a failure
of policing and the police culture but
also of politics
and i'm really quite worried that rather
like the way the metoo movement sort of
unleashed all of these testimonies
but then kind of drew back from
the kind of systemic change we needed
that we're at exactly a kind of
moment where the same thing could happen
we we can make in
we can make progress now people see what
the problem is
but they will be very easily distracted
and in a horrible way
this um churn with
cressida at the top of the police
this discussion the discussion of what
happened last night
it's all very important but it mustn't
distract from the bigger issue okay
and joan very briefly uh do you think we
should
be asking if she should go do you think
she should go
my personal view is that she's
mishandled this right from the start
right going back to wednesday when i
i was really taken aback by the
statement she put out when the
when the metropolitan police announced
they'd found human remains and i think
she's got the tone wrong from the start
and i agree that she knows her going
is actually not the most important thing
at the moment but i do think there's a
serious question about leadership at the
metropolitan police
okay dan let's go back to you um
a lot of women have been sharing their
experiences this week of harassment on
the street
of sexism in the workplace you shared
your experiences
you've talked about uh hearing a man's
footsteps and crossing the road as a
habit of a lifetime
have things got better do you think from
from those days when you first got
elected into parliament back in 1987
um just on the cretader dick question i
think it's important to remember that
the local
police in lamberth wanted the peaceful
vigil to go ahead or willing to work
with you
it was crested a dick and people at
scotland yard
that insisted on banning it all together
when everybody knew people would turn up
anyway
so she does have questions to answer in
relation
to experience of harassment on the
street i think in some ways it's got
worse
because what you've got is the online
world
which feeds um
hostility and violence against women
um and i was struck when i started to
think about it
how much i had always taken it for
granted
that the potential for violence by men
on the street was just something that
you
you had to guard against by crossing the
road
catherine do you think there is a link
through all of this
with with what you were trying to do
with women's equality party
fighting for equality equal pay equal
representation
this low level of misogyny do you think
that that is the root of the problem
that that then feeds into
the broader picture absolutely i mean
one of the things we've been seeing in
the pandemic
um the ways in which inequalities of all
kinds are laid bare the people
who are already vulnerable have been
made more vulnerable it has
been gendered in its impacts it has
hit people of color harder it has hit
people with disabilities in different
and harder ways and what you see
play out now with with this
and with this whole discussion in fact
is
um as as what we're all trying to talk
about
is the endemic nature of this
and the fact that it has not been
tackled it is never tackled it always
um you know you'll see tinkering about
the edges
but it isn't treated like terrorism
or as a form of terrorism as something
that is absolutely
central and that is linked to all these
different sort of
cultural strains to an education system
two forms of inequality
that feed back into this and amplify it
and so
what you need to do is in a moment like
this where you can see those mechanisms
you need to lay them there and you need
to look for
leadership but you know in the political
sphere
i keep saying that there are these
excellent women like diane who have been
working for years trying to push this up
the agenda and yet it doesn't happen
and yet here we are at our age seeing it
in many ways as diane said getting worse
not better
so this is a question about priority
this is a question about understanding
the ways in which all of those different
inequalities make this
not just tragic but tragically
inevitable
and you know this is this is preventable
but it is only preventable
if it is made a national priority if
um men step up to the plate if male
politicians recognize this and if there
is a
a wider um a conversation
about and not just a conversation i mean
we have a a whole load of very specific
policy proposals on this um
including indeed making it
a national priority um
on on the you know um it should be
identified as a national threat
violence against women okay jess spring
and joan i mean i mean joan you
you know you've talked about living in a
society where some
humans are worth less than others do you
think
and as katherine alluded to that
possibly we have hit a turning point
possibly
something very good could come of this
very very difficult week
well i very much like to think so but at
the same time i feel a kind of
disconnect between what people
say on occasions like this when they're
horrified by
what's happened to a particular woman
which is absolutely horrendous and i
think we you know we all feel very
distressed about it
but some of these people who are
expressing you know
shock and outrage now are the same
people who will carelessly read about a
rape trial
in the newspaper and say god you know
why was she on her own at night why did
she go to that man's hotel room
so i think there's a kind of you know
this is there's always these moments
where it feels as if things are going to
change but what we've actually got
is a broken justice system and that
reflects
the misogyny of the culture that we
inhabit
so for years now we've been having we've
had so many rape reviews i could
probably paper the walls of my house
with their findings
it doesn't change anything the you know
the conviction rate keeps going down and
that is because
of suspicion and disbelief towards women
that it's very easy to say gosh what
happened to this woman was particularly
awful
but actually what's happening to
thousands millions of women is awful
but we don't believe them when they tell
their stories and politicians
actually you know there may be a bit of
you know at the moment politicians
saying yes this is actually this is
dreadful
but where are the national campaigns
where are politics where are
candidates mps councillors getting up
and saying
this is this is terrible this is enough
this has got to stop we have to change
the culture
right from the start i mean that's a
that's a good point isn't it diana
average i mean
we look at the government anyway
you know we're half of the country but
we're only a fifth of those who are in
the cabinet
only 34 to the house of commons 24 to
the conservative party um
westminster's been labeled pest minster
in the past because of issues
uh there with sexual harassment i mean
are we wrong to look to politicians to
change this you know should we be
looking
somewhere else oh in the end
when you want to see substantive change
in a society
the political process is part of that
and to be fair some of us as women mps
have spoken out about these things
but in the past it hasn't necessarily
been seen as news by the media
we need a change in culture we need the
media to take these things seriously not
when there is one dramatic case
but there's the steady reality
of violence against women but yes at the
end of the day
this needs legislation this needs
funding and this needs political action
and catherine briefly a lot of men this
week have been questioning what they
can do to make women feel safer you know
i was chatting to my husband about it
and he said well i always cross the road
if i'm
on my own on the street and there's a
woman because it's just something i was
taught when i was younger but
a lot of men don't do that do you think
that
that
possibly we will see a change in society
from men
understanding now what women silently go
through in their head
well diane's point about the media is
very important here it's great that
you're doing a whole program on it but
it needs to be the whole media
talking about this all the time and in
ways that
really make people understand and make
men understand that this is
their issue so it isn't just about
making women feel safer on the street in
those small ways
it's about understanding this as a daily
experience
for women that disfigures the whole of
society
you know that whole kind of thing about
not women trending again
and you know the point is it may not be
all men
who commit violence but it is all women
and it is
all men for whom this is an issue too i
mean one of the most bizarre things is
seeing people seeking
to minimize the experience of women by
saying that more men are
murdered than women yes by men 96
of murderers are men it is a problem for
men and it needs to be seen as one
that is for men to step up to the plate
and solve
so the awareness that you're talking
about is really important but it goes
way beyond this
this is a time for men to actually
understand
that it is in everybody's interest for
them to tackle the problem of male
violence
and joan just last thought from you you
referred to all the different reports
that have been carried out
uh into violence and how you could have
wallpapered your home with them
suzanne moore funnily enough this week
said that misogyny is the wallpaper
that we live with do you have any real
hope that that society
will change only if we can keep this
going and if men ask themselves
questions like
it's not just what do i do if i'm
walking down a dark street and i don't
want to frighten a woman
it's also what happens when your friend
makes a really nasty rape joke
or says something demeaning about women
that nobody else overhears
do you act on that um i think you know
men have to look at their own private
behavior as well and ask themselves
you know are they tolerating a degree of
misogyny which i'm afraid i've been
writing about them for most of my adult
life and you know it's disappointing
that
that we are still here but i do think
it's up to men to look at their own
attitudes the attitudes of their friends
and family
as well as you know talking about what
happens in public
joan smith catherine mayer and diana but
thank you all very much
for joining us for this special program